Eric Voss here with another new rock
stars hot tea The Last of Us episode 3
ends with this shot of an open window
Breeze brushing past the curtains as we
watch the truck drive off this was
confirmed to be a nod to the menu screen
of The Last of Us game which The
Producers initially intended to be a
loading screen for every episode of the
Season you'd see a different shot of an
open window coming up on your HBO Max
screen you press play and the episode
would begin they dropped this idea along
with the plan to begin every episode on
the shot of a basement door someone
banging on and scratching on the other
side this was the basement that Tess
barricaded her infected son inside of an
episode by episode we'd hear this kid
turning into a clicker so we'd go from
an open window to a locked basement
horror door I much prefer this one time
optimistic open window a bit better as
it symbolizes a flight to freedom for
the souls finally at peace